some breaking news come in to the Sky  News Center for you now it's official  the Fianna for leader Michael Martin has  just in the last few minutes being  elected as the new Irish prime minister  he is speaking now let's cross live to  Dublin and listen in they voted to  establish independent courts they  reviewed and questioned the work of  every department they looked at ways of  funding housing in Dublin they set  themselves the challenge of not just  talking about the problems of our  country but of developing solutions our  country has shown time and time again  that we can overcome the toughest of  challenges and we will do so again it is  in the spirit of a deep belief in the  role of democratic government with a  commitment to delivering the recovery  and renewal embodied in our program and  the determination to work tirelessly to  serve the people that I proudly accept  your nomination got a Miele mahogany  colour  [Applause]